[Musik]
Großoffensive oder endloskrieg schafft
die Ukraine die Wende das ist unser
Thema heute und damit einen guten Abend
ihnen es ist eine Blamage für die USA
ein 21-jähriger Soldat hat Zugang zu
geheimen militärischen Informationen und
stellt sie online offenbar um vor seinen
Gamer Kumpels anzugeben die Papiere
haben es in sich die Ukraine steht
militärisch schlechter da als viele
glauben die Verluste der russischen
Armee sind groß und Präsident silensky
wird von den USA abgehört wenn das
stimmt und danach sieht es aus was hieße
das für den Verlauf des Krieges und
welchen Einfluss könnte es auf die
weitere Unterstützung der westlichen
Verbündeten haben morgen treffen die
sich in Ramstein und heute rede ich mit
dem deutschen Verteidigungsminister
Boris Pistorius und mit diesen Gästen
Kiesewetter CDU Außenpolitiker
CNN Korrespondent Frederick Pleitgen
von der Zeit
und der Politikwissenschaftler Frank
sauer
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner
[Musik]
und die begrüßt alle Gäste noch mal sehr
herzlich jeden Tag kommen neue Papiere
der US-Geheimdienste die wir alle
verfolgen und sie sorgen für ordentlich
Aufregung der Täter wurde letzte Woche
festgenommen
in Shorts vom FBI abgeführt
der 21-Jährige nationalgerist Jack Teck
Sarah
IT-Fachmann und Waffen nah bringt die
USA in schwerstes Fahrwasser
dutzende top secret Dokumente kursieren
im Internet
von Jugendlichen geteilt wie kann das
sein
ich habe das Ministerium angewiesen zu
prüfen weshalb er Zugang zu diesen
streng vertraulichen Dokumenten hatte
denn die sind brisant große Zweifel an
Kiews Schlagkraft im Pentagon das ist um
die anstehende ukrainische Offensive
nicht gut bestellt ist und Washington
selinsky und andere Verbündete abhört
das Pentagon liegt Misstrauen welche
Kriegsziele sieht Washington als
realistisch an und welche nicht der
ehemalige nato-ober Befehlshaber Hodges
waren vor einer sich selbst erfüllenden
Prophezeiung
die US-Administration sagt nicht dass
die Ukraine gewinnen muss was wiederum
zu nur schrittweisen Lieferungen von
Kapazitäten führt um tatsächlich zu
gewinnen
Frank sauer ist bei uns
Politikwissenschaftler an der
Universität der Bundeswehr in München
das ist ein ganz schöner Körper um es
mal zu sagen Militär Geheimnisse
geheimste Papiere Munition Ausstattung
Pläne alle verschiedensten Datums
wahrscheinlich schon vor einem halben
Jahr angefangen ins Netz zu stellen und
offensichtlich wollte diese 21-Jährige
einfach nur angeben wem glauben Sie Herr
Sommer schadet er damit am meisten der
Ukraine den US-Amerikanern der
Glaubwürdigkeit allen Beteiligten würde
ich sagen also
ich denke mal es war ja klar dass das
Verhältnis zwischen Washington und tief
schon vorher nicht sozusagen eine
vorbehaltlose Unterstützung seitens der
Amerikaner war für die Ukraine ich
erinnere an die Diskussion um diese
Raketen lange Reichweite für Heimat
diese attacks da gab es ja schon lange
die Forderungen an Washington ob man die
auch nicht vielleicht liefern könnte
immer
gewesen das möglicherweise russisches
Territorium eben damit auch angegriffen
wird in Klammern das macht die Ukraine
natürlich trotzdem wie man immer mal
wieder merken Engels zum Beispiel der
Luft auf den Stützpunkt und andere Ziele
auch aber was ich sagen will ist es gab
Vorbehalte in Washington und es gab auch
wenn gleich die Kooperation sehr sehr
eng ist insbesondere insbesondere im
nachrichtendienstlichen Bereich ich
glaube es gab auch Vorbehalte in Kiew
und die sind natürlich jetzt nach diesem
Lied vermutlich noch größer geworden
also das ist natürlich eine sehr
unangenehme Sache ich will aber auch
zwei anschränkungen noch
hinterherschieben erstens sie haben das
gesagt die Informationen sind eine Weile
alt und auch so diese Einschätzung mit
Blick auf wie die Ukraine aufgestellt
ist gerade kam wenn ich mich sehr
täusche nur von einer Institution von
von der Defense enthalten sie und da
gibt es mehrere in den USA insofern ich
würde das vielleicht auch nicht
überbewerten verschiedenste Dienste für
verschiedenste Informationen der
US-Amerikaner waren vielleicht können
wir Pleitgen auch um eine Einschätzung
bitten cnn-kollege der vor allen Dingen
aus Moskau und Kiew jüngst berichtet hat
und auch aus Paris unvergessen aber uns
natürlich auch da helfen kann was meint
wenn horches mit dieses self-felling
Professor mit dieser sich selbst erfülle
dass die beiden Administration immer nur
so viel Waffen liefert nach seiner
Meinung dass die Ukraine nicht verliert
aber dass sie auch nicht gewinnt also
dass sie auch nicht z.B die Creme
zurückerobern kann oder weite Teile im
Don Bass zurückerobern kann und dass das
dann irgendwann einfach so lange
weitergeht bis dann einfach die USA auch
müde werden von dieser Unterstützung und
das ist dann irgendwann einfach so
aussehen könnte dass es dann einfach
nicht mehr ausreicht für die Ukraine um
da weiter Gelände gut zu machen und dass
wir dann in diesem ja wenn Pat in so
einer patzsituation irgendwann sind wo
natürlich
so ist das wenn die USA ihre
Unterstützung Versagen dann ist
natürlich ganz Europa da auch mit drauf
und dran dass dann die komplette
Unterstützung auseinanderfällt und das
ist dieses safe vorfilling professi dass
wenn man jetzt nicht genug liefert dass
man dann irgendwann eine Situation kommt
wo gar nichts mehr geliefert wird weil
man das einfach in einem auf Englisch
aber so hinstellt dass sie einfach nicht
gewinnen können das ist das sieht als
große gefunden es ist wichtig dass
vielleicht am Anfang zur Einordnung kurz
zu sagen um es auch zu verstehen warum
es Pistorius deutscher
Verteidigungsminister heute bei uns in
der Sendung das ist interessant sie dazu
zu hören sie verfügen natürlich über
Geheimdienst Informationen sie haben
eine Verantwortung für die deutsche
Bundeswehr natürlich aber auch für
unsere internationalen Aufgaben wie
gefährlich sehen Sie diese Leckage
die sind natürlich bedenklich aber ich
würde ihnen recht geben man sollte sie
auch da verhüten sie über zu bewerten
das ist ein Ausschnitt wir kennen ich
bin jedenfalls kennen nicht alle Seiten
die dort aufgetaucht sind ich würde
genau es kommen immer mehr wie viele es
am Ende sein werden werden wir sehen
nicht alles ist gleichermaßen brisant
und bedeutsam oder neu oder aktuell von
der muss man das glaube ich gelassen
einsortieren ernst nehmen muss man es
ernst nehmen müssen vor allen Dingen die
Amerikaner dass ein solches League
entstehen kann dass unautorisierte
Person an das Material ankommen können
ja Nationalgericht erschließt sich mir
jetzt nicht unmittelbar was ich aber
hervorheben will ist das Leute Austin
sehr schnell den Kontakt zu seinen
Kollegen und auch zu mir gesucht hat und
das Gespräch gesucht hat über gesicherte
Verbindung um aufzuklären um zu sagen
was er weiß versteht sich von selbst
dass ich das jetzt hier nicht ausbreitet
hat sehr schnell den Kontakt gesucht in
dem Bemühen das Vertrauen zu bewahren
das wichtig ist unter den Alliierten und
unter den NATO-Partnern und ich würde
auch dieser Theorie der professi
durchaus widersprechen wollen weil
ich glaube niemand kannst niemand kann
wirklich behaupten dass die Amerikaner
sich bislang zurückgehalten hätten wenn
ich die Zahlen richtig in Erinnerung
habe haben sie so viel an Waffen und
Material geliefert wie die ganze
europäische wie die ganzen europäischen
Mitgliedstaaten zusammen aber sie haben
auch immer rote Linien gezogen Herr
pistorisiert aber gesagt ich glaube das
ist nicht auf russisches Territorium die
Verteidigung was ja eigentlich
völkerrechtlich irrelevant ist oder
unsinnig ist die Verteidigung darf nur
auf ukrainischem Territorium stattfinden
gerade ja schon erwähnt worden die
Waffen sind danach ausgesucht worden sie
sollten eben auch nicht weit weiter
reichen sondern deshalb bittet seit 12
Monaten die Ukraine um diese
lang reichen den Kurzstrecken Raketen
also so überzeugt sind offensichtlich
auch die Tiere nicht naja ich glaube man
muss schon sortieren man es ist
selbstverständlich und völlig normal in
so einer Auseinandersetzung einer
militärischen das auch der Angegriffene
insgesamtische Territorium vorgreift
vorgeht um beispielsweise Nachschub Wege
zu unterbinden das ist das normalste der
Welt solange keine Städte eine
Zivilisten keine zivilen Bereiche
attackiert werden wird man das
notgedrungen akzeptieren müssen nicht
gern aber es gehört dazu um
Nachschubwege beispielsweise zu
unterbinden aber ich glaube das ist
nicht der Grund gewesen am Ende geht es
darum dass hier wirklich Waffensysteme
geliefert sind und rote Linien ob man
sie mag oder nicht man kann nicht immer
alles auf Zuruf und sofort liefern das
muss geordnet passieren es muss
abgestimmt passieren mit dem Partnern
und vor allem muss natürlich derjenige
der liefert und wir reden ja nicht über
Kleinigkeiten wir reden über hochmoderne
Kampfpanzer wir reden über hoch aber
hochgefährliche Waffen in jeder Form
dass man das tut in einer Art und Weise
die klar macht wir haben einen Auge
darauf wie diese Konflikt ausgetragen
wird also wenn die Ukraine bestimmte
Typen von Bomben fordert die weltweit
geächtet sind dann muss man Nein sagen
diskutiert und dennoch ist ja die Frage
gibt es auch in der Administration der
USA und sie verstehen auch warum nicht
das Frage eine Sorge vor einer
Niederlage Putins
gibt es eben dieses Misstrauen dass man
nicht so richtig weiß wie weit die
Ukrainer gehen werden sie überlegen noch
eine Sekunde und ich frage mal Roderich
diese Wetter wir haben Ihnen viel in der
Sendung gehabt er kennt sich aus in den
militärischen Dingen ist der
entscheidende Oppositionspolitiker bei
all diesen Fragen Herr Kiesewetter jetzt
ist auch selenski abgehört worden von
den US-amerikanischen Diensten glauben
Sie dass das auch noch mal ein
zusätzliches Misstrauen in ein
offensichtlich eben ohnehin nicht von
vorne bis hinten das Verhältnis bringt
gut es ist für selenski sicherlich
unangenehm aber wir können es ja nicht
ändern und die Frage ist wie bewertet
selenski das deswegen will ich da gar
nicht spekulieren für mich sind zwei
andere Dinge wichtig ich glaube es sind
wegrufen doppelter Hinsicht einmal an
uns Europäer schlichtweg mehr zu tun
weil die Ermüdung bei den Amerikanern
nicht auch noch bei uns greifen sollte
deswegen kommt es aus meiner Sicht
morgen in Rammstein er Pistorius sehr
stark darauf an dass Europäer ein
Zeichen der Geschlossenheit bringen und
das zweite ist was ganz gravierendes
nämlich durch diese leaks wird natürlich
auch transatlantisch ein eine
keilgetrieben ob wir wollen oder nicht
dass wir aufs nächste Jahr schauen was
ist im nächsten Jahr sind Europawahlen
wollen wir dass die Europawahlen unter
den Zeichen von Flucht und Vertreibung
stehen oder dass die Europawahlen ein
Zeichen des Wiederaufbaus Europa für die
Ukraine ist und daraus folgert für mich
natürlich dass wir alles tun müssen und
bin Ihnen dankbar für den Hinweis dass
man auch an russische Versorgungslinien
denkt dass wir alles tun dass die
Ukraine ihr Territorium wieder gewinnt
was völkerrechtlich zulässigt
doch noch mal und unbedingt herzlich
willkommen in der Runde all diese Butter
von der zeitgeschätzte Kollegin aus
Europa Expertin wir wollen nämlich auch
noch mal verstehen was wir aus diesen
Papieren erfahren über die Situation des
russischen Militärs also ähm wie ist da
die Situation in Bezug auf Munition Mann
und Panzer wie sieht es da mit den
Machtkämpfen aus auch da gibt es eben
interessante neue Informationen so neu
sind die ja gar nicht dann sie zeigen
eigentlich einen dieser ströses Bild der
russischen Armee die Verluste sind enorm
die sind nicht ganz so hoch so hoch wie
die ukrainische Seite sie manchmal
dargestellt hat aber sie sind enorm hoch
es gibt massive Verluste ist die Technik
ist aufgebraucht insofern zeigen diese
leaks eigentlich dass diese Situation
für beide Seiten sehr schlecht aussieht
für die ukrainische aber auch für die
russische und ich war davon jetzt gar
nicht so überrascht
vielleicht kann man das noch mal
deutlich machen um es dem Zuschauer auch
zu sagen
ist viel in Moskau gewesen aber eben
auch in der Ukraine also da nicht nur in
der Hauptstadt sondern eben in der
kriegsregion 200.000 Soldaten verwundet
und tot auf russische Seite sagen diese
leaks ist es ungefähr realistisch ich
würde sagen dass das idealistisch sein
kann also ich war vor ich habe es vor
anderthalb Monaten das letzte Mal in
bachmuter in der Region unterwegs und
wir waren da in
in Schützengräben mit ukrainischen
Soldaten die gesagt haben dass die dann
teilweise zu 20 im Schützengraben sein
und von 200 Russen überfallen worden
sind und ich finde auch also das was die
Alice gesagt ist natürlich absolut
richtig wir reden halt bei Russland über
ein Land das jetzt entschieden hat dass
es zur Zeit die richtige Strategie ist
Strafgefangene aus knesten zu holen und
den an Mördern anzubieten dass ihr frei
kommt wenn ihr in die Ukraine geht und
da als Kanonenfutter auf den
Schützengraben zulaufen und das sagt ja
schon relativ viel aus und ähm als jetzt
in Russland das letzte Mal war es war
vor ein paar Wochen da merkte man schon
dass die Stimmung auch gedrückter war
als vorher und was was man glaube ich
immer wenn man im Umgang mit Russland
schaut was man immer im Auge behalten
muss ist dass die das öffentliche
Messaging das öffentliche was Leute auch
von sich geben das stimmt oft nicht mit
dem überein was sie wirklich denken also
es gab da wirklich Leute mit denen die
mir auch immer
irgendwelche Bilder zugeschickt haben
von Putin wie auf den silenski
einschlägt als comic-bild und sowas und
wenn ich dann mit den Personen
gesprochen habe dann haben die mir
gesagt es läuft nicht gut wir müssen das
so schnell wie möglich beenden weil die
nämlich Angst haben dass ihre Kinder
eingezogen hat werden weil nämlich Angst
haben dass mit der Wirtschaft noch
weiter bergab geht das ist eine
Massenmobilisierung gibt und man sich
jetzt anschaut putin war jetzt glaube
ich gestern oder es kam die Bilder raus
wir eine Nähe von der Front wohl wahr
der hat auch keinen Weg vorwärts gezeigt
in allen in allen reden wir in letzter
Zeit gehalten hat absolut nichts wie er
sich das vorstellt wie das Ganze beendet
werden soll und das machen wir auch
macht Kampf innerhalb Moskau um Putin
herum der Putin selbst aber nicht
beschädigt oder das ist die jungen
Dollar Frage früher hatte man noch das
Büro das irgendwie auf den auf dem Roten
Platz stand und man konnte irgendwie
erkennen wo wer stand und zu verstehen
wie gerade die Machtverhältnisse sind
und wir wissen es derzeit einfach nicht
und der Krimi war schon vorher eine
Black Box ist es seit dem 24 Februar
vergangenen Jahres noch in einem viel
viel stärkeren Maße geworden was wir
wissen ist es gibt Kämpfe in den Eliten
es gibt
Flügel die für ein Ende dieses Krieges
sind und zwar nicht weil man Mitleid hat
mit dem Ukrainern oder einen
Friedensschluss will sondern weil man
sieht wie große Schaden für das eigene
Land ist
inwiefern diese Kämpfe Wladimir Putin
beeinflussen wissen wir schlichtweg
nicht und ich bin das skeptisch ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass man die mir
Putin in den kommenden Monaten sein Amt
und irgendeiner Form aufgeben wird und
das ist das große Dilemma man muss
eigentlich einen Weg finden
ohne Wladimir Putin in irgendeiner Form
eine Verhandlungslösung zu finden aber
er wird da sein und aus diesem Dilemma
führt gerade kein Ausweg weil wir ja
auch immer sagen Friedensverhandlungen
können gegebenenfalls überhaupt nicht
mehr mit Putin stattfinden eben weil das
Leid so unendlich groß ist dass er den
Ukrainern angetan hat aber auch das
wissen wir nicht wichtige Frage an den
Bundesverteidigungsminister hat
historius was wissen Sie über die Kraft
und Stärke der russischen Armee und über
die Position von Putin also über die
Position von Putin weiß ich auch nicht
mehr als Frau Botan logischerweise es
gibt viele Blicke die Glaskugel viele
Spekulation was ich höre aus Moskau ist
genau in die gleiche Richtung bisschen
zu der Tatsache dass es frühere
Mitglieder
ältere älterer Nomen kulturas gab die
nicht abwenden aber nur sehr dezent und
im Hintergrund und den Hinterzimmern
aber nicht wirklich offen und das glaube
ich wird auch so bleiben das ist die
ganze Situation die wir dort vorfinden
also wir wissen dass das was an Material
jetzt nachgeschoben wird aus den depotse
teilweise erbärmlichen Zustand ist
teilweise steinalt buchstäblich steinalt
Panzer aus den 50er und 60er Jahren
das ist wirklich die Situation gerade
was wir nicht genau wissen nicht genau
abschätzen können wie hoch ist die
Produktionskapazität im Hintergrund für
neues Gerät das spekuliert man über
Zahlen im dutzende oder 20er Bereich
aber in relativ langen Zeitraum aber das
ist wirklich dann wieder Einblick in die
Glaskugel deswegen glaube ich wenn man
den Ausgangspunkt zurückzukommen ist es
so wichtig dass die Unterstützung anhält
es kommt für die Ukraine jetzt darauf an
das zu bekommen was sie dringend braucht
und dazu gehört nach wie vor vor allem
Unterstützung bei der Luftverteilung
deswegen haben wir jetzt unser Patrick
System ein weiteres geliefert mit 100
Lenk Flughafen und ihre state ein neues
da ist jeder Schuss ein Treffer wie man
so schön sagt die sind massiv definitiv
und was effektiv Luft dafür System wo
wirklich jeder Schuss der Treffer ist
das sind die Dinge die die ukrainische
Armee jetzt braucht um den Luftraum über
dem Land zu sichern weil das ist das
große gefährliche Einfallstor und die
Zielgruppe und die Zivilbevölkerung zu
schützen und die Infrastruktur wozu
übrigens unsere alten Gepard Panzer
immer noch hervorragende Dienste leisten
die Horn alten gepard-panzer man glaubt
ja kaum sie sind ja wenigstens 50 Jahre
aber ich glaube ich nicht Sie also
sondern unsere eigentlich gerade
erschrocken ja ich bin grau geworden
aber so schlimm wollte einmal bevor wir
nach Ramstein gehen wollte ich noch mal
nach dieser Vertrauensbasis fragen weil
die Ukraine stehen ja nun vor der
angekündigten Offensive vor dieser
früher als Offensive sie wird von
manchen vielleicht zu sehr erwartet aber
auf jeden Fall gibt es eine Menge
Vorbereitung dahin was wissen Sie über
noch mal gefragt das Vertrauen heute
eben auch zwischen Washington und Kiew
in Bezug auf diese offensiv gibt es
einen Austausch zwischen den beiden
Regierungen darüber wird man hat man
sich informiert man sich gegenseitig
zentral das kann ich ihnen Detail nicht
beantworten aber also ich lese ja auch
nur offene Quellen und im Economist zum
Beispiel Stand zu lesen dass es in Kiew
also exakt fünf offizielle gibt die
präziser wissen wann und in welcher Form
diese Offensive stattfinden soll so und
jetzt ist es ja auch sehr gut dass wir
das hier nicht irgendwie besprechen und
beitreten weil es soll ja nach
Möglichkeit auch ein gewisses Element
der Überraschung auf ukrainischer Seite
noch gewahrt bleiben und ich will
vielleicht noch mal einen Punkt
sozusagen machen und ganz zum Anfang
zurückgehen zu diesem
zu dieser Aussage von General Ben Hodges
das ist nämlich glaube ich ein sehr
gutes Bild eigentlich diese sich selbst
erfüllende Prophezeiung aber wenn wir
jetzt mal die letzten 14 Monate
zurückschauen dann ist eigentlich die
Geschichte der ukrainischen Verteilung
tatsächlich eine der einer sich selbst
erfüllenden Prophezeiung wir hatten ja
zum Anfang gar nicht für möglich
gehalten dass die Ukraine sich überhaupt
länger verteidigen könnte und erst als
wir festgestellt haben oh die können und
die wollen dann haben wir angefangen sie
zu unterstützen und dann konnten sie
immer mehr und dann haben sie sogar
angefangen Territorium zurück zu hören
also ich würde schon dafür plädieren zu
sagen
was sind politisch aus deutscher Sicht
aus europäischer Sicht aus westlicher
Sicht die Ziele bei denen wir die
Ukraine unterstützen wollen ja und das
heißt nicht dass wir eins zu eins genau
dasselbe wollen was die Ukraine will
aber es gibt schon eine große
Überlappung und die sollten wir stecken
und da sollte der politische Druck dann
auch sozusagen auf den Kreml kommen
militärisch sind das dann noch mal
andere Dinge das sozusagen ob man die
Creme zurückerobern kann und solche
Dinge das muss man davon getrennt
betrachten aber politisch glaube ich ist
es klug zu sagen wir wollen entschlossen
und besonnen auf solche Dinge
hinarbeiten wie beispielsweise die
territoriale Integrität der ukratzt sind
wir jetzt auch noch mal bei dem
Vertrauen in die deutsche Regierung und
da ist wichtig zu sagen dass die Tiere
dass die Ukraine sich eben auch in Bezug
auf das was Berlin entscheiden wollte
und entschieden hat zur Unterstützung
der Ukraine auch nicht so sehr verlassen
konnte sonst hätte der Vizekanzler nicht
das vor gesagt
zu lange gedauert und war zu spät ich
weiß das ich glaube nicht alle deutschen
Politiker würden dasselbe sagen aber ich
schäme mich zu tief das ist viel zu spät
ist
vor 14 Tagen gesagt sind sie auch
beschämt nee also die Aussage von Herrn
Harbeck mache ich mir jetzt nicht zu
eigen ich glaube es war am Anfang
richtig zu beobachten die Lage zu
beobachten mit den Verbündeten zu
sprechen innerhalb der Europäischen
Union den Nato-Partner zu sprechen und
dann das zu tun was notwendig ich habe
nicht den Eindruck dass irgendwas zu
spät geliefert worden ist es hätte
vielleicht gut getan als ein oder andere
früher zu liefern aber im Kern glaube
ich hätte es keinen Schaden angerichtet
diese Diskussion um Marder und um unsere
Geparden und um das Leben ja aber noch
mal ich glaube dass wenn Sie heute mit
den ukrainischen Partnern reden dann
sagen die wir haben uns nicht zu
beklagen am Anfang hätten wir gerne mehr
schneller gehabt klar das ist auch
verständlich und vielleicht hätte man
das ein oder andere schneller liefern
können ich hätte persönlich auch das ein
oder andere wahrscheinlich schneller
entschieden aber dass ich mich für das
Schämen was entschieden worden ist den
für den Schuh würde ich mir jetzt nicht
anziehen
das Router den Vortritt das sind die
Ukraine durchaus anders das ist eine
eine gesellschaftliche Entwicklung in
Deutschland gewesen und ich finde diese
Gesellschaft hat ein enormen Weg
zurückgelegt und auch die
Bundesregierung definitiv das Meer und
mehr und mehr geliefert worden ist zu
Wahrheit gehört aber auch dass das alles
sehr viel Zeit gekostet hat wir haben
diese Zeit die Ukraine haben sie nicht
die Verluste auf dem ukrainischen Seite
sind auch deshalb so hoch die
menschlichen Verluste weil es dann
Ausrüstung fehlte weil es an
equipmentväter und selbst jetzt wo eine
gegen Offensive im Raum steht wenn Sie
mit den Experten telefonieren dann hören
sie das sie im Prinzip diese Links
bestätigen sagen es reicht nicht wir
sind nicht vorbereitet
von mir dazwischen ist diese Äußerung
von Habeck in ihren Augen illeroyal
gegenüber dem Kanzler oder ist es eine
notwendige entschuldigung ich glaube es
ist über den aus europäischer ich glaube
es ist eine persönliche Bemerkung habe
ich war ja vor dem Krieg in Mario Pool
einer Stadt wo die Front 13 km entfernt
lag und er machte sich ja damals ein
Bild und und das war eben vor dem 24
Februar 2022 und wagte sich damals vor
mit der Forderung oder mit der laut
gedachten Überlegung dass man Waffen an
die Ukraine liefern sollte und er war
damals der einzige in der
Bundesregierung und hat dafür
nicht in der Bundesregierung aber war
glaube ich sogar der einzige in seiner
Partei und der
defensivprügel eingesteckt und und ich
glaube dass man seine Äußerung in diesem
Kontext sehen muss dass er damit schon
gesehen hat dass es notwendig war es ist
nicht geschehen und die Situation wäre
heute vielleicht eine andere wenn man
die Ukraine auch vor dem 24 Februar 2020
und trifft dann auf alle Partner in
Westeuropa und der westlichen Welt und
nicht nur auf Deutsch Deutschland
geliefert haben sonst wäre die Ukraine
tatsächlich nach drei Tagen
deutsche Gesellschaft und die vor allem
die Regierung vor allen Dingen deutsche
Gesellschaft auch einen Weg zurückgelegt
der weiter war als der Weg den andere
Gesellschaften zurückgelegt haben und
ich bin ehrlich gesagt jetzt nach dieser
Zeit wirklich froh über den Weg der sehr
konsequent gegangen ist und zurückgelegt
worden ist weil wir sonst nicht da
Stunden wo wir heute stehen nämlich als
größter Geber von Material und Waffen
auf dem europäischen Festland und ich
glaube auch
dass du dich anerkennen und trotzdem
muss man sagen dass dieser Weg das den
Preis für diesen Weg andere bezahlt
haben möchte ihn dann einen Punkt
widersprechen ich denke wir hätten
bereits im September mehr tun können der
Nato-Generalsekretär hat damals den
Aufruf gemacht Munition zu produzieren
wir haben viel geliefert aber keine
Ersatzteile wir haben nicht Munition
nachbestellt das Runterladen wir ja bis
heute also ich würde das jetzt nicht ins
schöne Stellen sondern habe ich sehe ich
hier als sehr selbstkritisch es war auch
nicht beabsichtigt dass das öffentlich
wird und ich wünschte mir da dass
dadurch austeile der Regierung
selbstkritischer umgehen denn die
Bevölkerung war viel weiter als die
Regierung zwei Drittel haben gesagt wir
tun zu wenig oder ausreichend nur ein
Drittel war dagegen und wir haben ja mit
dem sogenannten verzeihen Sie die
comicsprache doppelpunkts 300 Milliarden
Euro in die Hand genommen aber zu der
Zeit der Ukraine mit 1% der Summe mit 3
Milliarden geholfen und ich glaube da
ist eine Chance vertan gewesen zwischen
Juli und Dezember der Kanzler war seiner
Zeit im Auswärtigen Ausschuss und sagt
die von Marder wäre eine furchtbare
Eskalation und leider ist eben damit
nicht ein Auftrag an die Industrie
verbunden gewesen auch mit der Planung
zu beginnen da haben wir sechs sieben
Monate verloren die uns jetzt sehr viel
kosten aber leider auch in der
Reputation Spanien wollte damals hat
sich zurückgenommen Kampfpanzer liefern
Polen hat angefragt und unser
Bundeskanzler sagte ja wir tun alles
abgestimmt aber die Bitten der Länder
auf informeller Ebene wurden erst einmal
auf die lange Bank geschoben das haben
wir überwunden da bin ich auch sehr
dankbar das konnte ich dem Kanzler auch
sagen aber wir müssen zugestehen dass 7
Monate verloren gegangen sind die uns
jetzt schon auf die Füße fallen weil die
Amerikaner natürlich auch argumentieren
wir leisten fast zwei Drittel an ziviler
Hilfe und militärische Hilfe wie die
Europäer jetzt tut endlich mal was denn
es ist ja ein Krieg auf europäischen
Boden also da gehe ich nicht ganz
konform mit ihm nicht ganz ich
interessant weil es ist das Gegenteil
Lust Stopp schade nein also worüber
reden wir jetzt wir reden über
Verzögerung die in der Vergangenheit
passiert sind wir müssen nach vorne die
Frage der fragen uns einmal Sekunde ich
geh gucken nicht gleich nach vorne wir
fragen uns einmal wird uns wenn die
Ukraine verliert selbst historius wird
uns nicht nur aus Europa aber werden uns
die Ukraine die Osteuropäer die beiden
vorwerfen dass wir auf der Bremse
standen oder dass wir schneller sein
davon bin ich fest überzeugt dass das
nicht geschehen wird was alles was
danach passiert ist hat das vielleicht
nicht ausgeglichen und hat vielleicht
auch das nur eine Weile gebraucht um das
fehlende Vertrauen wieder aufzubauen
aber heute ist das da heute zweifelt
niemand an der Loyalität der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland niemand an
der Bereitschaft zu liefern was immer
lieferfähig ist ich glaube daran kann
heute niemand mehr zweimal dann hat es
in der Ukraine meines Wissens auch
niemand und wir liefern dafür auch
keinen Anlass von daher wird man am Ende
des Krieges der hoffentlich nicht mit
einer Niederlage der Ukraine ausgeht
wird man nicht für die Angst wegen der
Anfangszeit des zögerlichen vielleicht
zögerlichen Handels der Bundesregierung
hier die Schulter vergeben können das
wird nicht cool wenn die Ukraine
verlieren sollte dann hat Europa ein
anderes Problem als die Frage nach
deutschen zögern
ich kann das Objekt also ich kann es
vermeintlich Objektive formulieren und
kann sagen wie groß ist der militärische
Schaden auch weil Deutschland so lange
zögerte völlig unabhängig davon wie
dieser Krieg ausgeht ich möchte einen
auch das und das muss man dennoch
trennen und kann sicherlich bei weitem
mit dem Kopf nicken und Fernsehen noch
mal hören der vor nicht weniger als 8
Wochen dem Spiegel folgendes sagte
ich muss Druck machen der Ukraine zu
helfen und ihn ständig überzeugen dass
diese Hilfe nicht für uns ist sondern
für die Europäer
das bezog sich auf Olaf Scholz also
offensichtlich hatte auch sie Lenski
nicht immer das Gefühl dass ihm vertraut
wurde und maximale Hilfe geleistet wurde
Hilfe nicht für uns sondern für die
Europäer
aber ich verstehe in silenski total in
seiner Sichtweise er ist in einer
absoluten Ausnahmesituation die wir uns
für uns selber gar nicht mehr vorstellen
können von daher glaube ich ist es
berechtigt und nachvollziehbar dass er
maximale Forderungen stellt die er für
notwendig hält und dass er nicht immer
zufrieden ist mit dem was geliefert
worden ist ich würde aber jetzt gerne
ehrlich wie jetzt seit 3 Monaten im Amt
ich bemühe mich nach Kräften das zu tun
was möglich ist voll das Vertrauen in
Kiew und in die Entscheidungen von Kiew
hat der Bundesverteidigungsminister also
ich glaube es gibt in so einer Situation
niemanden der frei von Zweifel wäre das
wäre doch unehrlich natürlich muss man
gucken und überlegt sich ist das alles
genauso wie wir das machen würden
militärisch taktisch das kann man sich
alles überlegen aber das ändert ja
nichts daran dass man trotzdem liefert
was zu liefern ist deswegen glaube ich
nicht an diese selbst erfüllende
Prophezeiung weil ich glaube das ist im
Augenblick alle tun was geht aber alle
stoßen auch an wie soll ich sagen
Kapazitätsgrenzen nicht der eigenen
sondern der der Produktion das will ich
an der Stelle auch daran dass zu spät
mit der Produktion begonnen hat und zu
spät auch Produktionslinien aufzubauen
weil es gibt ja viele Industrie die
schon lange sagen hier lass uns neue
Produktionslinien aufbauen vor allem was
Munition angeht da ist ja schon wieder
schon lange im Raum dass man da massiv
mehr produzieren das ist auch das was
ich von den Ukrainern immer höre das ist
es also Leopard 2 als ich da in einer
Freund ich war von Kriminal bis bachmut
an allen Ecken und Enden der Freund ich
habe selten eingesehen der gesagt er
will unbedingt Leopard 2 haben also im
Gegenteil haben wird mir gesagt ich
kenne jede Schraube von meinem t62 oder
meinem T-72 den Leopard 2 brauchen die
vor allem weil die kein Ersatzteile und
keine Munition mehr für ihre Panzer
bekommen weil sie einfach auf der Welt
nicht mehr gibt aber Munition für
Artillerie Munition für Mörser und
dergleichen das ist das ist das was Sie
brauchen und da da muss halt ein
bisschen mehr kommen
er hätte auf den Weg gebracht werden
können
irgendwie ein Munition hinten
eine zweigeteilt natürlich hätten die
Staaten im Westen viel mehr bestellen
müssen und können aber die Industrie die
in einer Kriegssituation die wir in
Europa haben ich sag mal nicht von
alleine sagt wir fangen jetzt die
Kapazitäten hoch wir wissen dass der
Bedarf da ist sondern den Auftrag
braucht
keine finanzierungsweise sie weiß doch
dass die Abnahme erfolgt und sie weiß
doch das bestellt wird das
Bestellprozesse zu lange gedauert haben
darüber müssen wir uns hier nicht mehr
unterhalten da sind wir jetzt schneller
werden gerade schneller deutlich
schneller aber auch das beschleunigt die
Produktion ja nicht wenn wir überhaupt
wissen Munition reden 155 mm bevor das
Pulver überhaupt in die Granaten kommt
muss es 6 Monate liegen und trocknen das
heißt diesen Prozess kann ich gar nicht
beschleunigen umso wichtiger wäre
gewesen früher mit der entsprechenden
pulvermunition zu Beginn aber auch
früher zu bestellen deswegen sage ja es
ist auf allen Seiten nicht optimal und
wie soll ich sagen
antizipieren gehandelt worden ich glaube
die Frage ist ein wenig also wir haben
jetzt in die Vergangenheit geblickt
was ist das Ziel dieser Gegend Offensive
und welche Ziele unterstützt Deutschland
unterstützt Europa unterstützen die
Amerikaner und da habe ich ein großes
Fragezeichen mein Eindruck den ich aus
Gesprächen Gewinne ist man stattet die
Ukraine so aus dass sie Territorien
zurückgewinnen können wie erfolgreich
wird man sehen und sie in eine bessere
Position zu bringen um dann tatsächlich
an einen Verhandlungstisch zu kehren
sich zu setzen aber das sie haben vor
ein paar Tagen vielleicht gesehen dass
zwei Wagner Söldner ehemalige
drehflinge die von Wladimir Putin
begnadigt worden sind
in Aussagen erzählt haben wie sie den
bachmut den Befehl bekam ein Keller von
Zivilisten zu räumen zu räumen heißt
hunderte Menschen erschießen darunter
Kinder einer erzählte mir ein
fünfjähriges Mädchen erschossen hat all
diese Gräueltaten sind erst kürzlich
passiert in diesem Jahr all diese
Gräueltaten werden in der Ukraine für
unglaubliche Schockwellen und für eine
Verhärtung sorgen und zu verhandeln wenn
gerade erst solche Erfahrungen gemacht
worden sind das macht es sehr sehr
schwierig nicht unmöglich aber es ist
sehr schwer dann zusammenzukommen hinzu
kommt ihr dass die Ukraine schon mal so
weit war zu Beginn des Krieges im März
hat selenski sein Vater gegeben
15 Jahre internationale Verwaltung
Verzicht auf die von Russland besetzten
Gebiete sogar Verzicht auf die NATO
Mitgliedschaft und die russische Antwort
waren die
kriegsverbrechenden
Flucht Autos gesehen habe also das sind
Punkte wo natürlich die u am Ende nicht
nur bitter enttäuscht ist sondern die
Bevölkerung auch sagt das geht ist ja
ein Ziel ein Krieg gegen die Bevölkerung
über 40.000 zerstörte nicht nur
Wohnungen sondern Elektrizitätswerke
Menschen die in den Kellern frieren und
wimmern ganz furchtbar also der Punkt
ist ja dass die Ukraine schon einmal
versucht hat zu verhandeln und dann kam
diese dieses wegwischen und dann hat er
auch haben die USA versucht auszuloten
burns der CIA-Chef mit seinem russischen
Gegenpart und die Antwort war wir haben
schon 20% des Landes das ganze Land
kriegen ja also wir müssen schauen dass
wir die Zeit haben und die Russen die
Uhr und der Uhr muss ablaufen wir sind
noch mal bei der Frage an den deutschen
Verteidigungsminister
und
was wollen wir schaffen in der Ukraine
das ist genauso wichtig und interessant
sie zu fragen
bis heute sagt Olaf Scholz dass Russland
den Krieg nicht verlieren da und der
Bundesverteidigungsminister sagt die
Ukraine muss den Krieg gewinnen ich will
jetzt nicht schon wieder ein Filmchen
spielen sie werden sich an das erinnern
was Sie gesagt haben wer hat das sagen
das heißt sie sind jetzt tatsächlich
derjenige der da auch die Maximen und
die Richtlinienkompetenz ich glaube das
Olaf Scholz schon ich gar nicht weiter
auseinander sind ich formuliere es nur
zugespitzt da ich sage die Ukraine muss
den Krieg gewinnen das heißt ja nicht
zwingend und das sollten wir uns auch
alle nicht wünschen dass der Krieg am
Ende militärisch gewonnen wird sondern
der ideal wäre ja dass wir einen
Friedensschluss kriegen oder ein Rückzug
der Russen der dazu führt dass das
ukrainische Staatsgebiet zurückkehrt in
die ukrainische Souveränität und
Integrität das muss das Ziel sein wie
das erreicht wird ist dann die zweite
Frage ich bin der offenen Ukraine muss
den Krieg gewinnen Russland darf mit
dieser Aggression nicht durchkommen darf
kein Erfolg haben das muss die ganz
klare Botschaft am Ende sein
Unterstützung
eine andere Kommunikation als ich er hat
eine andere Sprache als ich ich finde
das ist auch völlig okay im Ziel sind
wir uns trotzdem alle beide gleich und
sehr nah wir wollen alles lie wenn du
was geht und die Ukraine unterstützen in
ihrem Kampf gegen wo haben sie mehr
Freiraum ist ihre Vorgängerin
sie nehmen sich den Freiraum ich
behandle so wie ich handle und lass mich
gerne danach beurteilen sie bekommen
unsere Unterstützung wenn Sie das sehr
klar machen ich wünschte mir nur dass
die gesamte Bundesregierung sich so klar
äußert wie sie und der Punkt ist ja dass
sie mit Blick auf ihre Koalitionspartner
da sicherlich überhaupt keine
Überzeugungsarbeit leisten müssen
und bei uns auch nicht aber mir fehlt
ein bisschen mehr Klarheit innerhalb der
Sozialdemokratie und da müssen sie
Nacharbeiten nee muss ich nicht die
Sozialdemokratie voll und ganz hinter
Olaf Scholz und auch hinter dem was ich
hier tue ich habe nicht den geringsten
Zweifel dass wir den Weg weitergehen was
ich in völlig in Ordnung finde dass das
nicht alle mit Jubel geschreibt und dann
dafür ist es kein Thema es ist ein Thema
wo man sehr wohl unterschiedlicher
Meinung sein kann sehr wohl auch
differenziert denken kann sich sehr wohl
auch Sorgen machen kann und muss wenn am
Ende aber alle geschlossen dahinter
stehen dann kommt das für mich darauf an
das ist mir lieber als wenn alle mit
wehenden Fahnen hinterherrennen und tun
darauf verwiesen dass es berechtigte
Sorgen vor einem atomaren Krieg gibt und
dass ihnen diese Sorge auch zögern ließ
und nicht zu einem hurra Schreier
gemacht hat wie sie selber gerade sagen
versuchen wir doch mal zu definieren
wann hat die Ukraine gewonnen würden Sie
sagen die Ukraine darf zurückgewinnen
was bis zum 23.02 22 ihr Territorium war
würden Sie sagen sie darf zurückgewinnen
was sie bis 1992 das Problem mit solchen
mit solchen hypothetischen Linien die
man da sieht ich mag sie überhaupt nicht
weil sie immer dazu führen dass man sich
festlegt und am Ende feststellen wenn
ich das nicht erreiche ist nicht
erreicht worden was hätte erreicht
werden müssen ich halte das für wenig
vor wenig wenig zielführend die Ukraine
ist am Ende der souveräne Staat der
entscheiden muss welche Linie für Sie
das richtige ist nicht wie ich muss mir
aber ich kann mir darüber reden
eigentlich kann ich jetzt widersprechen
und sagen sie ist überhaupt nicht
souverän weil sie ja von unseren Hilfen
abhängt
Wohnzimmer souveräner Start und zwar in
der Frage wann will sie
friedensverhandlung mit wem führen unter
welchen Bedingungen mit welchem Ziel das
legen sich hier fest das wird der besten
ihr denn helfen
das sagen wir immer wieder und solange
wie wir können und solange wie wir
solange es nötig ist werden wir die
Ukraine unterstützen das ist die ganz
klare Linie der Bundesregierung so wir
sind Herr Sauer bei der Frage denn es
geht weiter mit dem Verstehen Rammstein
vor der Tür morgen kommen alle
Unterstützer der Ukraine zusammen und es
wird um diese Offensive gehen und auch
um die Offensive Fähigkeit der Ukraine
gehen eins wissen jetzt offensichtlich
schon mal alle es wird nicht noch mal
eine so erfolgreiche Offensive wie
letztes Jahr in warum
das ist vielleicht sehr wichtig das noch
mal zu unterstreichen also einfach um
ein bisschen erwartungsmanagement zu
betreiben die russische Seite hat
natürlich jetzt ausreichend Zeit sich
auch vorzubereiten auf diese Offensive
die natürlich antizipiert wird und
insbesondere natürlich im Süden der der
vermutliche Schwerpunkt diese Offensive
sein wird weil die Ukraine natürlich ein
Interesse hat Richtung militopol
vorzustoßen und möglichst die Landbrücke
da aufzuknacken
da sind entsprechend Befestigungsanlagen
geschaffen worden erdwelle Gräben diese
Drachenzähne so Panzersperren und
natürlich auch
Minenfelder und ich habe das neulich
gesagt ich sage das hier auch noch mal
wir sollten uns auch darauf einstellen
quasi Bilder zu sehen von brennenden
zerstörten auch Leopard und Marder
Panzern und anderen westlichen
gelieferten gepanzerten Fahrzeugen die
in diesem vorschluss zerstört werden und
da müssen wir uns als Öffentlichkeit
auch in der Diskussion drauf einstellen
aber ich will
trotz alles erwartungsmanagements
vielleicht noch mal da dazu sagen die
Ukraine hat ja zwei wunderbaren und das
sind keine technischen Geräte sondern es
ist a die eigene Kamera und B die
russische Inkompetenz und diese beiden
Variablen haben eigentlich von Anfang an
das Kriegsgeschehen bestimmt und wenn
sich an diesen beiden nichts drastisch
ändert bleibe ich dabei dass mit Blick
auf
Moral
Personalstärke und Material die Ukraine
hier eine gute Chance hat das zu
erreichen was wir uns alle erhoffen ja
und so schwer ich auch finde das
Verhandlungen überhaupt vorstellbar sind
aber das was wir uns erhoffen ist
ein verhandlungsfrieden der kein Diktat
Frieden ist und das ist nur möglich wenn
auch durch unsere Hilfe die Ukraine sich
in eine möglichst gute
Verhandlungsposition gibt und dazu
gehören politisch auch solche Dinge noch
mal politisch solche Dinge wie die
glaubwürdige Androhung
Druck auf die Krim ausüben zu können
noch mal ob das militärisch geht ich
weiß es nicht ich vermute niemand weiß
es in tief ist es bestimmt auch viele
nicht aber es muss sozusagen als
Verhandlungsmasse auf dem Tisch liegen
um einen Herrn Putin oder wer auch immer
an den Tisch zu zwingen und zu sagen
okay jetzt muss ich verhandeln und mein
Eindruck ist auch
da gebe ich auch Frau Butter vollkommen
Recht oder es wurde jetzt verschiedene
genannt dass in westlichen Hauptstädten
dass das narrativ ist dass es im Grunde
jetzt gilt dass das entscheidende Jahr
ist hat auch was mit Wahlen zu tun in
den USA und so weiter und so fort
spielen viele Faktoren mit rein und im
Grunde die Ukraine jetzt diesen Zustand
möglichst herstellen muss und ich
fürchte Schrägstrich vermute dass dann
auch der Druck auf Kiel wieder größer
wird zu sagen okay also jetzt müsst ihr
schauen ob wir nicht doch irgendwie zu
einer Verhandlungslösung irgendwie mit
Russland kommen könnte die linke Seite
geographisch linke Seite ist gleich dran
was denken sie werden sich die Ukraine
morgen in Rammstein erbeten
also das was ich schon gesagt habe
weiter massive Unterstützung bei der Air
Defense also Luftverteidigung das ist
eine ganz zentrale Frage die werden
sicherlich das Thema Jets wieder
aufbringen da sind wir als
Bundesrepublik weitgehend raus aufgrund
der Flugzeuge die wir im Portfolio haben
die F16 auch nicht wirklich geeignet
also muss man wirklich sehen was am Ende
geht aber das ist eine Diskussion die
wir werden morgen werden wir morgen
führen und es wird vor allen Dingen
darum gehen das ist ein Thema was
ähnlich wie er Defense oder Munition vor
einem Jahr noch weitgehend unbeachtet
geblieben geblieben war eine Diskussion
jetzt auch unbeachtet zu drohen bleibt
nämlich die Frage wie finanzieren wie
gestalten wir eigentlich die
instandsetzungsapps für die
Gerätschaften die wir geliefert haben
also die Leopard Panzer die mörderpanzer
die Panzer Haubitzen die da haben wir
den habe in der Slowakei der läuft jetzt
endlich nach Monaten von
verhandlungsschwierigkeiten
für die Leoparden entsteht der in Polen
aber das kostet richtig Geld das muss
finanziert werden und da werden wir
morgen sicherlich im sogenannten Panzer
Lunch wie wir das dann nennen auch mit
dem Klingelbeutel rumgehen müssen wir
wer bezahlt es denn jetzt am Ende
Rumänien soll der marderhabt werden
Instandsetzung und das sind richtig
kostenintensive Maßnahmen weil diese
Panzer natürlich im echten
gefechtsbetrieb ganz anders beantwortet
werden gewartet werden müssen diese
Kurzeinsatz genau diese langfristigen
Planung sind das was 2020 hat vermissen
lassen denn selbst wenn morgen auf
wundersamerweise der Frieden aus breche
was wir uns wünschen würde die Zeit der
Sowjet Waffen ist vorbei in der Ukraine
das heißt sie müssten besseres Material
haben und das auch auf Dauer nutzen
können das ist der nächste große
Unterschied dieser neuen Offensive der
Ukraine dass es nämlich an den
Materialen Mix gibt wie man sagt und wir
auf der anderen Seite verstehen uns auch
das einzuordnen das ist eben wieder von
allem nicht genug ist da kommen dann
Beginn des nächsten Jahres diese 300
Panzer an die der Westen schicken wollte
und die stehen dann 3000 russischen
Panzern gegenüber anderes mehr also ist
die Situation der Ukrainer wie
geschildert tatsächlich so dass die in
der Offensive erfolgreich sein können
das müssen wir auch mal auf die
Habenseite schauen denn unsere
Bevölkerung will ja auch wissen was wird
denn geleistet die westlichen Staaten
haben über 60.000 ukrainische Soldaten
ausgebildet die derzeit in Ausbildung
sind und die werden alle im Zeitraum bis
Mai Juni in der Ukraine zurück sein mit
ihren jeweils verschiedenen Waffensystem
die größte Herausforderung für die
Ukraine ist die Logistik die Versorgung
die Instandsetzung und natürlich die
unterschiedliche Ausbildung und das muss
zusammengeführt werden das glaube ich
möchten wir der Bundeswehr in der Form
nicht zumuten aber die haben keine
andere Wahl und die Ukraine sind äußerst
finde ich in der Vernetzung in der
aufklärungsvernetzung in der Frage wie
sie feuerbefehle durch Sensor die durch
Sensoren die sie haben also
aufklärungssysteme miteinander
zusammenbringen da können wir lernen und
jetzt kommt ein Punkt wo wir nach vorne
schauen müssen die Ukraine leistet ja
sehr viel für die Verteidigung Europas
sie bekommt dafür auch sehr viel aber
wir sollten jetzt hier nicht zaudern und
sagen sondern sagen mit welchen
Sicherheitsgarantien versehen wir denn
die Moral der Ukraine hat die Ukraine
eine Aussicht EU-Mitglied zu werden ja
hat die Ukraine Aussicht naturmitglied
zu werden dann wir unterschiedliche
Auffassung ich sage ja die Ukraine muss
NATO mit denen dass die einfachsten
Sicherheitsbedingungen beinhaltet auch
wenn sie am Anfang etwas aufwendig sind
wir brauchen etwas wo die Ukraine sich
dran festhalten kann die ukrainische
Bevölkerung den Putins Ziel ist ja
Massenflucht ist durch die scheußlichen
Kriegsverbrechen die Menschen sagen wir
haben keine Perspektive und wenn wir ihn
nicht das was völkerrechtlich zulässig
ist geben dann wird die Ukraine keine
Zuversicht haben die Menschen kommen zu
uns also haben wir etwas so nächstes
Jahr sind die Europawahlen insofern geht
es jetzt darum dass Morgen und Signal
ausgeht Europa steht zusammen und dass
wir auch unsere Bevölkerung sagen die
60.000 die da ausgebildet werden die
werden ein Mehrwert bringen wie sie
eingesetzt werden ist Sache der Ukraine
aber sie verdienen dann auch jegliche
Unterstützung und wir müssen etwas mehr
unserer Bevölkerung erklären aus der
Wissenschaft aus dem Journalismus aus
der Bundesregierung aus dem Parlament
weil unsere Bevölkerung auch in Anspruch
darauf hat dass hier der Erfolg den wir
vorbereiten durch diese Entscheidungen
Ihnen auch erklärt wird das ist noch zu
wenig wie erklärt man jetzt ganz klug
dass wir plötzlich auch die mit 29
durchwinken und wie wichtig die ist und
fragen uns alle gemeinsam ob die Ukraine
jetzt das als eine als eine deutsche
Unterstützung empfinden oder alter
ich glaube auch nicht dass die Mick 29
dann großen Unterschied machen wird
plötzlich und ganz schnell noch mal sehr
viel konzentrierter wird gerade was die
Munition ich glaube das geht nicht ich
glaube das ist von der Ukraine in der
Tat sehr bald ein sehr großen Push geben
wird weil es gibt diverse Sachen die wir
jetzt in diesem Krieg ja schon gelernt
haben eine davon ist dass die westlichen
Waffen den östlichen Wörtern
meilenweit überlegen sind wenn ich mir
das angucke im im ich glaube das war im
September oder im im Sommer letzten
Jahres da warst du was die Russen
Offensive bei Lissy Chance hatten im
Osten von der Ukraine wo die ganz
langsam wie so eine Walze wie im Zweiten
Weltkrieg nach vorne gekommen sind die
Amerikaner haben dann auch noch zögern
erstmal vier Raketenwerfer geliefert wir
haben damit die komplette russische
Armee außer Gefecht gesetzt weil die
nämlich einfach hinten dann alle
Munitionsdepot zerstört haben und die
konnten sich nicht mehr vorwärts bewegen
das gleiche haben sie dann auch gemacht
bei Herr Sonden die haben sie die großen
abgeschnitten und die mussten dann
darauf also es ist es ist wird schlimm
werden es wird aber spannend sein zu
sehen wenn das wirklich so ist dass die
westlichen Waffen zum ersten Mal in
einem Gefecht auf diese Waffen aus
Osteuropa treffen wie das dann sein wird
ich glaube die russische Armee immer
noch viel gefährlicher ist als viele
Leute das Denken ich glaube dass die
Russen sich da unten eingeigelt haben
das ist sehr schwer sein wird diese
defensiven auf Button zu durchbrechen
aber sobald die durch die Friede
verteidigungsringe die sind also wenn
man sie erklären
riesiger Fluss den meiner teilweise
überquer ist ja auch kein kleiner Fluss
wo man wo man erstmal rüber muss ich
glaube das wird super schwer aber die
ukrainische Armee hat schon gezeigt dass
sie einfach besser und vor allem
motivierter ist also die Motivation
lässt sich sehr schnell ausbilden sehr
schnell aussehen obwohl bei den Panzern
als auch bei den bei den
luftwaffensystem bei der Artillerie sie
ist wahnsinnig lernfähig dann wahnsinnig
lernfähige Männer und Frauen die
insbesondere auch wahnsinnig schnell
lernen zu reparieren weil das ein
existenzieller
auch erzählt haben als ich die an der
Front getroffen habe das ist so und auch
wenn man die Leute in den
Zivilbevölkerung stehen sehe ich glaube
dass viele Leute denken oder oder fühlen
dass die ukrainische Nationen mit jeder
Bombe die auf Städte geworfen wird immer
stärker wird die werden immer stärker
weil die ich jetzt aufbauen die haben
jetzt ihren existenziellen Kampf die
stellen sich sie gewinnen diesen Kampf
an so gut wie allen Fronten ich glaube
auch nicht dass die dass die Russen
diesen Krieg gewonnen hätten wenn wir
keine Waffen geliefert hätten die wären
dann vielleicht in ein paar Städte
eingedrungen aber die werden dann im
Grill der Krieg untergegangen die
Ukraine sind echt stark und es wird auch
so bleiben ob wir helfen oder nicht aber
die Frage ist wie stehen wir dann da wie
steht Europa da die Ukraine die wird das
schaffen
das wirklich der Blutseite der in diesem
mehr als einem Jahr bezahlt worden ist
von der Ukraine ich habe heute mit
jemanden gesprochen sagte die die die
Männer und die Frauen die kämpfen sind
müde sie sind aufgebraucht es gibt Leute
die seit Monaten an der Front sind weil
die Rotation nicht stattfinden kann und
diese Leute sind erschöpft und die das
Ausmaß an Verwundung ist furchtbar sind
deine ganze Generation geben von
Menschen Menschen die mit amputierten
Gliedmaßen Leben und und die die das
Straßenbild prägen werden aber
gleichzeitig sagte dieser Mensch mir
eben auch und trotzdem wissen Sie wenn
sie auch nur einen Schritt zurückgehen
dann ist alles verloren es ist alles
verloren dieses existenzielle was Herr
Pleitgen betont hat das ist das ist sehr
wichtig man muss sich das mal verstehen
ukrainische offensiver bis hat ja in
dieser Zeit eine russische Offensive
stattgefunden die ist gebrannt die
finden
schaffen es ich gehe jetzt seit ich
glaube September letzten Jahres nach
bachmut und war schon ein paar mal da
seitdem höre ich bachmut Feld in zwei
Wochen und es ist sie sind immer noch da
die haben immer noch nicht verloren in
bachmut und die halten das trotzdem noch
das ist die 316 größte Stadt der Ukraine
die schafft die Russen die schaffen die
Russen nicht diese Stadt zu nehmen und
das zeigt er schon dass die Ukraine und
gleichzeitig bereiten sich auf ihre
eigene Offensive vor
die Streitkräfte eben doch nicht ganz so
wirkungsvoll sind dies ist aber man muss
natürlich dabei auch bedenken dass eine
offensive viel schwieriger ist als als
Defensivarbeit also wenn man bei Uniform
beginnen dann dann ist das schon auch
nicht nicht so einfach eine Sache fällt
mir noch mal ein oder besser gesagt sie
fällt uns nicht ein sondern sie ist sie
auf meinem wunderbaren Display weil es
ja eine
gerade eben auch dem deutschen Militär
eine große Bewunderung für die Stärke
der russischen
Militärs gab und vor allen Dingen ja
vielleicht auch nur Respekt unter
anderem Eberhard Zorn hat sich dazu
verstanden
die Masse der russischen
Landstreitkräfte ist derzeit zwar im
Krieg gegen die Ukraine gebunden
dennoch sollten wir das Potenzial der
russischen Landstreitkräfte einen
weiteren Kriegsschauplatz zu bedienen
nicht unterschätzen
der fairnesshalber muss man sagen das
ist schon ein bisschen her Herr
Pistorius man kann trotzdem die Frage
stellen ob auch das ein Grund war dass
sie gesagt haben sie möchten sich von
eberhardshorn trennen also auch diese
Einschätzung hatte damit überhaupt nicht
zu tun sondern andere Gründe die damit
zusammenhängt dass ich gesagt habe wenn
wir jetzt einen neuen Weg einschlagen
wollen neue Strukturen einziehen wollen
einen neuen ein neues mindset
produzieren wollen dann braucht es auch
an der Spitze den die einen den ein oder
anderen Wechsel und damit schlicht ist
das begründet okay und dann sind wir
jetzt bei genau der Frage wie Europa in
das muss sie schnell noch mal nachfragen
wie Europa
sich jetzt aufstellen wird wie sich die
Kontaktgruppe der Ukraine aufstellen
wird um in Rammstein eigentlich der
Ukraine was zu versprechen können wir
eine Mitgliedschaft der EU versprechen
können wir eine NATO Mitgliedschaft
ernsthaft Versprechen der Pistorius also
morgen in Rammstein kommen wir nicht nur
die Europäer zusammen da kommen ja
starten Videos ist dann 3 Monate später
morgen ist das Thema NATO Mitgliedschaft
der EU-Mitgliedschaft überhaupt kein
Thema ich glaube das zum Thema
EU-Mitgliedschaft alles gesagt ist der
Weg der Weg wird frei gemacht aber es
muss eben trotzdem so sein dass die
Voraussetzung für einen u-beitritt
erfüllt sein müssen daran können wir
auch nicht nachlassen finde ich dafür
ist die Europäische Union dann auch in
der Zukunft zu wichtig und die NATO
Mitgliedschaft auch dazu gibt es eine
Beschlusslage das wird zugegebener Zeit
entschieden werden die Tür ist ein Spalt
auch aber das ist jetzt nicht der
Zeitpunkt das jetzt zu entscheiden aber
es ist wichtig ist den Ukrainern
vielleicht irgendwann mitteilen
die Beschlusslage aus Madrid was glaube
ich oder noch älter immer Dritter glaube
ich die kennen die Beschlusslage man
wird sich damit beschäftigen man ist wo
man ist aufgeschlossen aber das nur dazu
muss man jetzt erstmal diesen Konflikt
diesen Angriff abwehren und dann in der
neuen Zeit muss man diesen Schritt genau
abwägen das ist keine Frage die man
jetzt mal eben so aus Solidarität trifft
weil er eben Wirkung hat das muss man
wirklich auch in aller Besonderheit tun
da muss man mit kühlem Kopf und heißem
Herzen entscheiden und nicht umgekehrt
aber es wird morgen gegebenenfalls auch
die Gespräche hier und da dazu geben
solltenberg war heute in Kiew
überraschend in Kiew und hat Zielinski
das noch mal in Aussicht gestellt dass
die Ukraine zur NATO gehört wie heikel
das ist haben wir hier auch schon
besprochen weil man es jetzt für den
jetzigen Zustand ohnehin nicht erwägen
kann und es tausend andere Gründe gibt
auch dagegen Einwände zu haben weil
Putin entsprechend
eskalieren könnte wohin denken sie wird
glauben Sie nicht sagt der käsewetter
ich frage sauer wohin glauben sie wird
es am Ende laufen wird man Ihnen sagen
eher Europa als NATO und wir rüsten die
Ukraine so auf dass sie sich wie Israel
verteidigt fühlt durch uns das ist auf
jeden Fall der erste Schritt also da
sind ja auch schon konkrete Vorschläge
gemacht worden von vom ehemaligen
Nato-Generalsekretär anders gibt es ja
so diesen Security compact wo er mal
aufgeschrieben hat wie sowas aussehen
könnte und
in dieser Sicherheitsplan Entschuldigung
muss ich immer einmal kurz übersetzen
genau und in vor diesem Hintergrund ist
auch mein kommentar von vorhin zu
verstehen gewesen also man wir müssen
uns schon sehr klar darüber werden dass
diese Hilfe jetzt nicht so eine
einmalige Sache war um eben diesen
Verteidigungskampf dazu organisieren
sondern die Ukraine wird dauerhaft ja
massiv militärisch ausgestattet und
ausgerüstet werden müssen um in gewissen
Sinne sich auch
einzueigeln und Stacheln zu haben so das
bestandte wieder aufbauen genau um eben
sozusagen zu verhindern dass Russland so
eine Aggression noch mal versucht das
heißt das ist das eine und dazu gehören
dann unter Umständen dann in einer
größeren Planung auch noch andere Dinge
zum Beispiel ja Snapback Sanktion sagt
man also Sanktionen die im Prinzip
getriggert werden wo man klar sagt wenn
X dann Sanktion y so das Russland im
Prinzip auch weiß was da auf sie zukommt
und natürlich wieder Aufbauhilfe etc
dran wie wird das aktiv bewertet ich
könnte mir schon vorstellen dass das es
da viele gibt die sagen das reicht uns
nicht ja also ich bei EU und NATO ich
sehe das ganz genauso ja also ich meine
wenn wir an den westbalkern
beispielsweise denken und wie lange der
Prozess da ist und wie groß unfassbar
umfangreich diese Kataloge sind
anforderungskataloge die ein Land
erfüllen muss um die EU zu kommen das
dauert erster Punkt NATO sehe ich
zurzeit auch wirklich nicht weil im Land
das
territorial nicht intakt ist würde die
NATO nicht aufnehmen ja dann hat man ja
sozusagen sich das Problem schon in den
Kopf das heißt es wird im Prinzip auf
sowas hinauslaufen und wie kieft dann
darauf reagiert wage ich jetzt nicht zu
prognostizieren ich könnte mir schon
vorstellen dass es da nur runde Stimme
gibt die sagen eure Sicherheit Garantien
hat mir schon mal 1994 Budapester
und wir geben unsere Atomwaffen
hätte auch nie toleriert dass die
Ukraine die in irgendeiner Weise behält
also das ist so ein bisschen hier so
eine Schimäre so eine Scheindiskussion
als ob die die hätten behalten können
aber trotzdem das narrativ ist im Raum
und man wird vielleicht in Kiew sagen
wir haben uns einmal darauf verlassen es
hat nicht gereicht den Fehler machen wir
nicht nochmal und dann haben wir
natürlich politisch natürlich ein
Problem unterstellen sie dass sich Kiew
Atomraketen besorgen können um sich also
es ist ein Gedanke es ist ein Gedanke
der durchaus in Fachkreisen bewegt wird
das unter Umständen die Ukraine dann
sagt dann werden wir uns eben unilateral
darum bemühen möglicherweise in
nukleares abschreckungsdispositiv doch
wieder zu haben das würde der Vergleich
zu Israel katastrophale Folgen natürlich
haben fürs nicht verbreitungsregime ja
die müssten aus diesen Vertrag zur NATO
also
verhindern
ich will nur dafür sensibilisieren dass
sowas passieren könnte und deswegen ist
es so wichtig dass das wieder machen
also wirklich wasserdicht und felsenfest
ist und substanziell ist und wie gut
dass wir hier darüber gesprochen haben
und wir haben verstanden Herr Pistorius
dass der Atem offen wirklich nicht mehr
so richtig lang ist und widersprochen
bisher sollen so schrieb das Wall Street
Journal macron und Scholz Olaf Scholz
volume selensky signalisiert haben dass
sie sich ein Ende dieser
Frühjahrsoffensive diese Offensive ein
Ende der Kampfhandlungen im Herbst
dieses Jahres wünschen ähnlich gut zu
Pass käme es der Washingtoner
administrationsum jetzt mal sehr salopp
zu sprechen wie lange ist unser
Atembereich der tatsächlich nur bis zum
Herbst dieses Jahr ich glaube nicht dass
das der das jungtim war sondern ich
glaube das war der Wunsch ich meine wer
wünscht sich das an diesem Tisch oder in
diesem Land oder in Ukraine nicht dass
dieser Krieg so schnell wie möglich
beendet wird damit war nicht verbunden
die Ansage länger können wir nicht wir
wissen doch nicht wie lange wir was
können das hängt von der Geschwindigkeit
haben in der Produktion aufgebaut werden
kann das hängt von der Bereitschaft
aller Länder ab auch weiter viel viel
Milliarden auszugeben für die
Unterstützung der Ukraine davon hängt
das ab aber ich glaube am Ende weniger
vom Willen und vom können
Runde noch mal hier ganz schnell
vielleicht gehen was glauben Sie ich
glaube dass das dass die Unterstützung
noch sehr lange weitergehen kann ich
glaube dass das auch sehr lange
weitergehen wird ich glaube in Amerika
so da stehen ja nächstes Jahr Wahlen an
wenn Donald Trump Präsident wird dann
dann können wir die Ukraine noch mal eng
werden ich glaube dass der den selenski
nicht ausstehen kann aber ansonsten ich
glaube selbst ronde Säntis würde das so
weitermachen für die USA ist das so das
ist eine sicherheitspolitische
Entscheidung da stehen die meisten
Republikaner dahinter da stehen auf
jeden Fall so gut wie alle Demokraten
hinter das das wird dann sicherlich noch
so weitergehen die Ukraine
das ist jetzt ja wir sind jetzt ja im
Territorium in dem man einfach noch nie
war wo so viele unterschiedliche
Waffensysteme jetzt zusammengebracht
werden für eine große Offensive muss man
erstmal gucken wie wirkt das Ganze und
dann wird man sicherlich ein bisschen
Leergeld Zahlen gucken was funktioniert
und was nicht und wo steht man am Ende
davon und dann gucken wie es weitergeht
aber ich glaube man muss man
signalisiert ja dass das dass das offen
Ende ist ist Unterstützung
dieses vortasten geht weiter deiner
Frage ich gleich noch mal Alice Butter
weil gefühlt vorgestern waren
kampflieger und Jets natürlich noch ein
Krieg Eintritt des Westens und jetzt ist
das durchaus auch im Bereich des
Möglichen und wir alle gehen in diese
Ungewissheit was glauben Sie wie lange
die Unterstützung des Westens reichen
ich glaube die Unterstützung mit lange
reichen in welche Intensität sie
stattfindet ist die andere Frage und
darf nicht eben zwei Punkte wichtig die
wir wirklich öffentlich wieder und
wieder diskutieren müssen gegen
Offensive und Verhandlungen schließen
sich nicht aus sondern Bedingungen
einander
und die Sicherheitsgarantien wir reden
darüber fast gar nicht und man könnte
sogar sagen dass die eigentliche Arbeit
die eigentliche Unterstützung beginnt
wenn ein eine Art von Frieden
tatsächlich verhandelt worden ist dann
muss die Ukraine in der Lage sein so wie
Israel in der Lage ist sich gegen seine
Nachbarn zu verteidigen sich auf
Jahrzehnte gegen einen mächtigen
Nachbarn zu verteidigen definitiv Ulrich
Kiesewetter wie sieht die Lastenteilung
aus zwischen Europa und den Amerikanern
sie haben es gerade erwähnt mehr Europa
koordiniert durch Deutschland der
deutsche Führungsanspruch ist da den
müssen wir jetzt unterfüttern und dafür
jegliche Unterstützung und morgen kann
dafür ein erster Anfang seinen Rammstein
wie kann man das jetzt gut Teilen mit
den amerikanischen Produktion in Europa
Ausbildung aber auch entsprechende
Waffensysteme aus Europa in die Ukraine
liefern so dass die Amerikaner die
satellitengestütze machen die Aufklärung
aber europäische Rüstungsindustrie für
die Ukraine das stärkt uns auch
entlastet die Amerikaner mit Blick auf
den Elefanten im Raum das ist China und
Tai wan und deshalb stärker die
eurostunde Europas schlagen lassen und
bis dahin
geklärt ob es noch ein bisschen mehr
Geld für die Bundeswehr gibt ich kläre
das mit allen mit denen das nötig ist zu
klären und ich bin nach wie vor sehr
zuversichtlich dass es signifikant sein
wird das muss auch signifikant sein
und der vielleicht auch daran
anschließend ein Schwerpunkt unseres
Engagement ist neben der Waffen
Unterstützung die Ausbildung wir sind
der stärkste Ausbilder unter anderem
unter allen weil wir nämlich nicht in
der Masse nur ausbilden sondern vor
allem auch in der Qualität was Kommando
Strukturen angeht auf Bataillons und
divisionsebene was die Frage von
Feldwebeln angeht das ganz ganz wichtig
die Unteroffiziere einer Armee sind das
Rücklagen ja so das ist sehr sehr
wichtig ja ich sag sogar geht das im
Grunde genommen
dass wir die ausgebildet haben und
weiter ausbilden eine kleine
ausbildungsstunde machen sie auch gerade
in ihrem Ministerium und ich frage
trotzdem noch mal diese 10 Milliarden
werden jetzt kommen haben sie da schon
irgendwie Signal kommen im Raum steht
eigentlich mit Inflationsausgleich ja
oder wenn Sie die zwei Milliarden für
den Tarifabschluss wenn der so käme also
das muss man alles dann mal auf den
Tisch legen und sagen das und das muss
sein wenn wir handlungsfähig und
investitionsfähig bleiben wollen dafür
trete ich an und dann gucken wir mal was
rauskommt aber das ist nicht meine
eigene Entscheidung Parlament überzeugt
und Parlament überzeugen genau danke in
die Runde vielen Dank für die Debatte
heute
wir entlassen sie nicht in die Nacht
sondern zu Markus Lanz der heute unter
anderem Stefan weil zu Gast hat den
Ministerpräsidenten aus Niedersachsen
ich darf mich ganz herzlich bedanken wir
sehen uns nächste Woche wieder wenn sie
können und mögen die gleiche Stelle
gleiche Welle bis dahin tschüss vielen
Dank
[Musik]